especially when you see artemiev has
just under three minutes on the clock
and this is why uh farouja has made a
bid to complicate the position
yeah but it's just looking for
sacrifices oh sacrifice pawn takes pawn
played
yeah and that's just oh yeah frozen is
panicking that last move it shows he's
desperate to try and clarify the
situation he wasn't happy to maneuver
anymore it was costing him too much time
but now white is simply a pawn up and
white's queen can go and grab a pawn
later white bishop can jump out attack
the black queen can
can artemia be even more bold and attack
the knight and the bishop and yeah he's
played it okay yeah i missed this one i
think faruza missed this one as well
that's a double attack white's pawn is
about to win a piece
for roosevelt he's losing on the board
and the clock he's about to be a piece
down and he's a minute and a half down
just tired after a long day
the situation
is difficult pressure i think our tamiya
is too experienced uh in this site he
chose the right opening
not reacting at all he knows he's
completely winning at this point black's
bishop gives itself up the white queen
can just take that bishop and it does
yeah so now a whole bishop up for all
right and uh
just 47 seconds left on the clock
a piece down oh he knows it and
oh this unfortunately extra piece and
it's a very strong piece as well look at
why it's bishop on a great diagonal
all white needs to do is prevent any
traps against the white king any threats
there and okay i'll tell you if again
consumer professional just keeping
things simple pushing pawns forward if
that pawn's captured white will initiate
a queen trade and that will just make
things easy so
again taking more risks because he knows
he's in
trouble this is a neat
very efficient tribe by uh tamiya he
steps forward with his queen and now the
threat is actually to potentially give
some checks and also paul takes pawn in
the air
and
yeah for russia it's hopeless he's
trying something he's trying to just
confuse artemiev by playing on the yeah
and
weaving a mating net on the board i mean
the situation is just hopeless in fact
the computer is telling me mate in eight
yep that's if black defends the to the
maximum but there's no chance feruzio
resigns
it's over for the 18 year old but
vladislav or tamiya he is
so fantastic in this format in his third
tournament in the meltdown champions
chess tour makes it to his second final
he will face magnus carlsen in the final
of the aim chess u.s rapid wow